la parole est à eric doligé pour le
groupe l'est républicain deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état au budget monsieur le
ministre la france va mieux
pourtant 85 % des français ne sont pas
satisfaits de la politique proposée par
le président de la république
à titre d'exemple sur 100
téléspectateurs qui vous regardent en
cet instant 85 ne vont pas se satisfaire
d'une réponse sur le thème du tout va
mieux
ils sont dans la vraie vie faite de
difficultés et attendent des résultats
accessibles
oui nous nous réjouissons de la baisse
de 60 mille chômeurs de catégorie a mais
les soixante mille ans - sont venues
nourrir les rangs des emplois précaires
des entrées en stage ou ont fait l'objet
de radiation massive
où est le cynisme que disons-nous aux
trois millions cinq cent trente et un
mille chômeurs de catégorie a qui sont
sans emploi
six cent quarante cinq mille de plus que
depuis votre arrivée
est-ce que cela va mieux pour eux
puis-je ajouter que la situation
économique s'est fortement dégradée que
la dette continuent à s'envoler
représente un risque majeur que les
économies annoncées ne sont pas au
rendez-vous et que nous nous faisons
distancer par les grandes nations
européennes
dans cette période où il faut faire des
économies le président annonce à chacune
des interventions des dépenses nouvelles
à titre d'exemple point d'indicé de la
fonction publique le plan de formation
la généralisation du service physique la
prime à l'embauché le rsa etc
en quelques mois c'est presse de 11
milliards de dépenses nouvelles qui ne
sont pas financés dont une partie
significative sera reportée après 2017
monsieur le ministre n'est-il pas temps
de rompre avec cette politique de
promesses intenables reporter et qui
s'apparente en cette période deux
dernières années de quinquennat à des
promesses électorales pour vous répondre
la parole n'est pas il serait kert
secrétaire d'état en charge du budget
monsieur le ministre deux minutes
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
le sénateur votre question appelle deux
angles de vue le premier
je vous invite à nous dire puisque vous
avez pointé une liste de ce que vous
appelez des dépenses nouvelles
je vous invite à nous dire lesquels sont
superfétatoire lesquels sont inutiles
fallait-il renoncer un plan de formation
pour les chômeurs dont vous pointez le
nombre trop important fallait-il
renoncer à 900 millions d'euros
d'allègements de cotisations pour les
professions agricoles qui en ont
tellement besoin fallait-il renoncer à
ce que les bas salaires dans la fonction
publique soient dignement reconnu par
une trop légère 10 diront certains
augmentations du point d'indicé
donc plutôt que de stigmatiser et
d'additionner d'ailleurs pardon de vous
le dire comme ça avec la franchise
habituelle des dépenses de 2016 2017 et
2018 pour arriver à des chiffres 11
milliards qui représente une addition
comme on dit dans le monde populaire de
carottes et de navets 4 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires seront
nécessaires pour le budget 2016 suite
aux annonces du président de la
république je les ai passées en revue
rapidement et hier nous avons eu
l'occasion dans cet hémicycle d'en
débattre
comment seront financer ses dépenses
c'est le deuxième angle d'observation de
votre question elles seront financées
comme l'an dernier
l'an dernier à la même époque vous aviez
les mêmes discours dire que ce que nous
avions mis pour la sécurité des français
ce que nous avons mis pour la défense
notamment extérieure de notre pays vous
disiez on ne saura pas le financer fin
de l'année dernière le déficit a été de
3 5% lieu de 3,8 soit 6 milliards de
moins que prévu donc ayez confiance
travaillons ensemble pour que des
économies supplémentaires puissent
financer des dépenses nouvelles dont
vous vous devez de conclure avec nous
quelles sont nécessaires merci messieurs
2010 monsieur doligé en 20 secondes
oui je m'attendais bien sûr monsieur le
ministre à la qualité de vos réponses
je sais que je parle un poids lourd du
gouvernement donc ça va
et quelle serait la nature de vos
réponses mais très sincèrement non mais
très sincèrement vous savez que voulait
reporter pour la plupart au delà de 2017
vous savez aussi que les économies ne
sont pas faites vous savez aussi oui
mais vous montrez bien sûr ce que nous
compterons vrai 2010 m
comme nous nous vous avons dit que
c'était pas possible
alors ça vous conclure pour terminer à
titre amical je voudrais vous dire que
dit au président de la république qui ne
cherchent pas monsieur macron le 8 mai
qui sera orléans pour les fêtes de
jeanne d'arc